.
Pour gravir les escaliers,
il faut enjamber lébébébris
et dans l'appartement éviscéré,
tout est perdu. Pourtant,
Olga nettoie d d d défiance, lae
et les larmes se tiraillent
une place dans le coeuriviviviv.
La peur, elle, beaucoup
l'étouffent. En plus
d'un mois de guerre,
ukrainien, la dévastation est
à plusieurs chapitres.
- Je crois que ça nous fait
tous mal de réaliser que
nous sommes tous en daacacacacas
par l'agression russe dans les
zones d'opérations militaires.
Ils ne tirent pas dans les airs
mais pour tuer, poststststststsx
de réaliser que nous étions
des voisins, des parents.
Nous avions un lien.
Mais aujouaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa,
de proches, d'idéologies.
- Il n'a pas quivvvvvv
depuis le début de la guerre,
mais il voudrait bien convaincre
de se mettre à l'abri.
En plein coeur de la ville,
e,e,e,e,e,e,e, des résidences,
de commerces ou des positions
militaires, il ne semble
ou logique aux frappessssssssss.
Le métro de Kharkiv est devenu
un l l l l l l les habitants
qui vivent toujours ici.
Une vie parallèle
chanceux onte e e e e e e dans
les wagons du métro à l'arrêt;
un peu de confort et d'intimité
C'est ici que n n n n n n n n nt
des couvertures posées à même
le sol. Elle y vit depuis
deux semaines avec sa fille,
son peti
son sphinx adoré.
Beaucoup n'y viennent que passer
la nuit maisplplplplplplplplplp.
- Je crains que mes nerfs
ne tiennent pas.
C'est difficile chaque foispopo.
Parfois, je monte les escaliers,
je marche un peu, maààààààààààà.
ses habitants font de leur mieux
pour donneviviviviviviviviville
qui fonctionne envers et
contre tout. Même scarifiée
russes, la ville reste
et fonctionnelle et on cherche
à protéger son patrimoine p p pé
encore touché. Les frappes
s'en prennent aussi aux symboles
de
de l'administration régionalet .
Il a été visé par 5 roquettes;
mortes le 1er mars dernier.
S'il n'avait pas eu un peu deder
à cette liste.
- - - - - - - - - - Dans les qus
résidentiels du Nord et de l'est
de la ville, lesabababababababa.
C'est ici que se concentrent les
frappes des Russes. Les maisons,
les écoles, les jardinsntntntnts
des cimetières pour ceux qui
restent. Encore la nuit
dernière, 7 personnes sont
mort
blessées dans le quartier.
Quand la Russie frappe,
les rescapés sont conduits ici :
blessures par ba
multiples fractures ouverte,
crâniens. Des c
se faire à une médecine qu'ils
s s s s s s s s s s shrapnel
logé dans l'intestin, q q q q q.
j j j j j j j j j j j j j j j s
resteront meurtries.
Le directeur médical
les tremblements de son visage,
vengeance quand il raconte
commen
un sanctuaire protégé a à son
tour été ciblé par l'armée russe
ANDRYI
Centre de traumatologie
- Je pense qu'ils commettentoros
spécifiquement pour nous
intimider. Oui, parce qu'au XX
siècle, avec la géolocalisatioùt
se trouve. Il esèèèèèèèèèèèèèèè.
il a sauvé la vie au début de la
guerre
regard s'ajuste à la pénombre.
Ces vieillards accompagnés
de quelqa a a a a a a a a a a ae
du jour depuis près d'un mois.i,
des bénévoles risquent tout pour
leur porter de quoi survivre.
trtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrte
fin, c'est tout ce qu'ilsdededeu
la guerre à l'aube de leur vie,
ils vo a a a a a a a a a a a a t
que terrés comme des rats.
une question qui hante au détous
de Kharkiv. Parce que nous
répondre ici et que c'est chezas